this was one of the most intensive
exchanges of missile and drone strikes
so far in the war attacked drones struck
six regions inside Russia with the most
Northerly Target an air base near the
city of pascov where it's reported more
than 20 drones were used starting large
fires
four giant transport planes on the
ground were hit although the extent of
the damage is disputed by both sides
Moscow says it downed many of the
attacking drones accusing Kiev of
targeting civilians assisted by its
Western backers
Ukrainian drone attacks on civilian
objects confirm the terrorist essence of
the cube regime once again it's clear
that Ukrainian drones weren't able to
fly those distances without assistance
from Western satellite information
Russia has warned the strikes will not
go unpunished as is often the case
Ukraine hasn't confirmed it's behind
these latest strikes merely referring to
them cryptically as accidents happening
on Russian territory but leaders in Kiev
say that airbases used to launch attacks
on Ukrainian territory are legitimate
targets
just before Daybreak Wednesday much of
Kiev was awoken by a series of
explosions as more than 40 Russian
drones and missiles targeted the city in
waves from all directions with Ukraine
claiming to have shot down nearly all of
them
but there were casualties with several
people killed and injured in what's said
to be the largest Russian attack in
months with every indication of more air
strikes from both sides to come Rob
McBride Al Jazeera Keith
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera